thirty-six no hi my name is Andy Andy
I'm Danielle how are you
Zack will today we are blindfolded and
we're gonna try to guess each other's
age all right
what movies did you watch growing up um
of course a lot of Disney but I was
watching the old school animation
none of this Finding Nemo CGI craziness
do you snapchat I do not use snuff
do not use no okay what was your
favorite childhood trying to think I
liked fruit snacks a lot
who was your favorite band when you were
in high school who you are cause my
favorite musician I want to take a stab
at it I'm gonna guess that you are 31 no
okay Backstreet Boys or insane um
Backstreet Boys got it okay you
Backstreet Boys I didn't like any of
that okay
I loved in sync when I was younger and
then I still love JT for me I was a
Destiny's Child girl
okay did you vote for Bill Clinton yes
36 No
so were you in elementary middle or high
school when Monica Lewinsky and Clinton
Monica Lewinsky was like one that was
like 98 mm-hmm I think it was freaking
early oh wow he's the baby I think just
23 22 do you remember the first CD that
you bought I do
[Laughter]
don't judge me it was MC Hammer I don't
know if this is gonna work as well but
do you still have cable
yes okay all right cool then I'm gonna
put you in and around the bracket with
my sibling so we're just like a touch
older than me well I should let me
preface this by saying it's not my cable
it's my mama's cable okay well that but
I stream it all right well then we're
back to the first I guess dance craze I
remember really hitting was the mucker I
okay you know what the microwave yes I
do
we did that we did that and like when
you were 18 when it was I had the
Macarena
we had migrated at different times 28 no
38
no what was your first cell phone one
kind a Nokia the one that had like the
game replay snake on it 27 no 31 no and
I call Sarah you're closer 333 I am we
did it I'm trying to have five you we're
literally ten years apart what was the
first car you remember having an you're
a kid I remember a station wagon don't
have the wood paneling on it yes you
either have to be born in the early 80s
or the very late seventies 39 no but
really close 40 yeah
I mean I can't see you directly but I
wouldn't have guessed you're recording
oh god I'm gonna embarrass myself on the
BuzzFeed you got you're right there
you're right there yes boom you are 28
years old
no I'm 29 okay well there I was so it's
close sorry you were very close yeah 29
nope 30 no am i close
no 32 no did you ever have a blackberry
no I never had a blackberry I give up
hey how old are you 38 that was really
tough I was really hard the snapchat
question was good yeah I couldn't know
what I know in their thirties of the
snapshots you get the exact number it
was difficult but to get in the range
once I knew what her cartoons were when
she was a kid it's pretty smooth sailing
from there I didn't know what I was
stepping into you know you get presented
with the blindfold you know you don't
know what you'll end up doing
[Music]